let's talk about ex machina wonderful
film and getting so much attention you
play a robot with artificial
intelligence and here you are this is a
photograph that take a lot of makeup
because I was amazed it's very I don't
think there's any CGI in this film and
any CGI I think I just had a great diet
so you could see my robot yes there's
some CGI but I was impressed with how
authentic I mean it is quite compared to
most studio yes it has a very small
budget so I think probably half the
budget went to just creating me right
but whatever you saw that poster it's
kind of the form so the silver match
that she has was just like a full
bodysuit and they built my forehead on
top of my skull which was you know my
hair was in a bald cap every day did you
have to wear that costume then all day
long because people forget about that
you get made up and they probably get
you up at 4:00 in the morning gets you
into the costume and then you have to be
in it all day and even go to lunch as
the robot I did you know I put my arms
I'm song and my like tracks pants and
you know you kind of forget or you kind
of know what you normally look like and
then you go out to have lunch and I just
go you forget you like it's a robot with
no stomach you compared robot acting
like a robot to sort of acting drunk
because and I'm just curious what I
meant by that no but it was that thing
oh you kind of you know come in and I
knew that I was gonna play a robot and
you know you kind of have I don't know
ideas of what that should be like and
Alex Garland the director can I help me
to know that you know the wish of this
robot is to be a girl's a focus on be a
girl and then go back finding kind of
that of beaten glitches for people to
question how be not human in the same
way that you know you think you played
wrong you don't try to act drunk you
kind of try to be a person who trying
not to be drunk yes that's no it's
almost becoming like forgetting yourself
way I thought that performance is
absolutely stunning